>>I'm Jeff Jarvis.
I blog at buzzmachine.com and teach journalism
at CUNY.
And my part of the world, what we need to
do to change the world for
innovation, is to get in entrepreneurship.
I think the future is entrepreneurial more
than institutional.
The institutions, which is pretty much here
at Davos, are the ones that
are disrupted.
We need to bring together the disruptors and
to find ways to support
them.
I teach entrepreneurial journalism at CUNY,
which is not an oxymoron.
And I think we have to bring entrepreneurship
to many industries and to
enable the future to be built.
It's going to be painful but let's get there
faster than later.